didn't see me but here I am beefmaster
[Music]
it's been a thousand years since Trump
drain the water I'm running out of time
I need water I need a water supply
hello I'm so thirsty I'm pissing dust I
don't have much time left
there's only one way
pray to the goddess
[Music]
Oh goddess grant me this way
I'm a Buddhist oh my god thank you so
much love you so much the marina's draw
a legendary lute
tastes just like her the marina straw
filters any form of liquid with this I
make make it out of love now I just have
to find something liquid right there
I'm not gonna be sick am i you turkey
you tested this yeah
documentary Brad how did you make it
bless the choice
Oh oh [ __ ] wrong end [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] Oh
Sweetwater
[Music]
that was some great juice but I need
more I've had this bottle of bleach I
wonder could the marina stick filter it
yes it's either that or I'll die but
what's the [ __ ] difference
[Music]
what this
I could use this bomb for my bleach
give me that bleach give me that
it's my bleach my precious juice
[Music]
say look gay
this is a tough one to filter it's
almost like it's Polly felt a drink
[Music]
the bleach the source of life
I drank all the liquids there's only one
source left but I'll have to kill
someone
meanwhile a word from my sponsor
[Music]
we're sponsored by loot crate this is
last month's crate antihero from August
loot crate services change every month
on the 19 September steam will be speed
hmm I wonder what that could be
sonic flash team let's check inside my
god fixed we have a t-shirt Penna do you
know where this is from oh oh that's
right Michael do you want oh my god
socks I've never had socks before when I
kill bill socks this dog's wear socks
well they do now
[Laughter]
Harlequin bigger we put on the lucrative
tail boy more like hell yeah it's a
money bag we need one of those that's
perfect Annie's a brofist
oh my god there's there's a paint
there's dogs wear pins here we go
alright I'll put it on this car okay
congratulations you're on official
sellout
how does it feel great alright what if
what a bum bum ass box remember so check
out loot crate dot-com slash Puetz
entered the code Puetz you get 10% off
[Music]
you didn't see me but neither did he
it's time to clink
[Music]
it's a gay you to drink from another man
tastes like survivor
yes just like my dad wait wait a minute
this fake blood you're not even dead are
you you [ __ ] [ __ ]
I got a reputation to protect him get up
get the [ __ ] out man you don't even
longer inna that was three weeks of
dinner damn it [ __ ] there's only one
thing left me
bloody bleach my favourite it's time for
to drink my own juice the source of that
and you see my dick are you pissing
right now yeah really weird oh [ __ ] I
had a lot more than I thought yeah boys
come on me
[Music]
oh that is not filthy [ __ ] out oh
that's a good [ __ ] I can filter this
[Music]
let's get this is so dark man it's a
drink a glass of water that's healthy
that's healthy no it's a good it's a
good shade marina would approve I am the
ultimate survivor
there's only one thing left to do
[Music]
I need to go to another planning
remember to check out loot crate calm
slash Puetz into the code Puetz you get
10% up Tammy wants to take
come on
they don't never do wearing a life
jacket beats Mouse 264 should I be
wearing a life you can't swim
I can swim you know what's divorce me
darts
we're getting close now cameraman are we
gonna be legends don't we [ __ ] leg
Barris oh my god